hoy en directo a Vamos hasta Bolivia
porque la Comisión Interamericana de
Derechos Humanos condenó Este martes la
violencia y cualquier uso excesivo de la
fuerza en las protestas que llevan
varias semanas en el país esto al tiempo
que los bloqueos están siendo levantados
porque los manifestantes se preparan
para una gran huelga este 25 de enero
para ampliar estas noticias conectamos
con Mary vaca corresponsal de France 24
que se encuentra en la ciudad de la paz
Mary Qué otros detalles se conocen del
informe de la Comisión Interamericana
Hola Qué tal Buenas noches la Comisión
Interamericana de Derechos Humanos en
conjunto con la relatoría para la
libertad de expresión han emitido un
comunicado en esta jornada condenando
los hechos violentos durante las
protestas realizadas en Santa Cruz este
comunicado condena por un lado el uso
excesivo de la fuerza por parte de las
fuerzas de seguridad del Estado pero
también la violencia provocada por
grupos civiles el reporte indica que en
Santa Cruz se han producido
enfrentamientos entre la sociedad civil
y los policías dejando varios heridos y
también periodistas afectados y
agredidos por estos enfrentamientos por
otro lado se reporta que se han
registrado alrededor de 25 hechos de
vulneraciones a los derechos humanos en
Santa Cruz por el otro lado la comisión
indica que en Santa Cruz los grupos
civiles han arremetido en contra de
instituciones públicas se sabe que a
muchas de ellas han sido quemadas e
incluso una vivienda de un ministro a
resultado afectada Por tanto la comisión
y la relatoría para la libertad de
expresión instan al Estado boliviano a
que garantice el derecho a la protesta
de los ciudadanos y además garantice la
protección de los ciudadanos cuando
concurran a estas protestas en
diferentes partes del país Eri
justamente que se espera para la jornada
del 25 de enero en Bolivia
bueno los dirigentes cívicos de todo el
país han tomado la decisión primero de
suspender las medidas de presión que se
habían prolongado durante 20 días tras
la detención del gobernador Luis
Fernando Camacho para luego concentrarse
el día 25 de enero en las nueve
capitales del país en un Cabildo
nacional esto quiere decir que va a
haber concentraciones ciudadanas en
estas capitales donde se va a preguntar
a la gente Qué tipo de protestas y
acciones se deberían tomar en contra del
gobierno de Luis Arce para exigir la
liberación de los 180 presos políticos
según los dirigentes que existen en el
país entre ellos el gobernador Luis
Fernando Camacho también los dirigentes
cívicos quieren Según dicen recuperar el
estado de derecho defender la democracia
y evitar que se instaure una dictadura
en Bolivia según el pronunciamiento
conjunto que han hecho una reunión de
estos dirigentes cívicos Se ha producido
en Santa Cruz al término de la cual los
dirigentes de Santa han decidido
suspender las medidas de presión de
hecho esta misma noche se terminan de
suspender los últimos bloqueos pero se
mantienen las vigilancias ciudadanas
alrededor de las instituciones estatales
como una medida de alerta de emergencia
y de protesta